even before birth Trish Jackson's body
was irreparably damaged by phalidomide
her mother took the drug to treat
migrains and then discovered she was
pregnant it's not just the arms um I had
a lot of internal damage as well I had
uh six holes in my heart and heart and
lung problems and I was a blue baby
wasn't supposed to live um but I here I
am still here the lamide was build as a
wonder drug and was widely used in the
1950s and early 60s to treat morning and
nausea but it caused severe birth
defects with many women miscarrying or
losing their babies after birth 60 years
after it was taken off the shelves the
Australian Parliament has
apologized we are sorry for the harm and
the hurt and the hardship you have
endured we are sorry for all the cruelty
you have had to Bear we are sorry for
all the
opportunities you have been denied a
senate committee found that the
government failed to recall the drug
despite Global warnings and that if it
had acted more quickly 20% of survivors
may not have been
affected worldwide more than 10,000
children are believed to been born with
birth defects because of the use of
flamide with an estimated 40% dying
within a year and while the survivors
here in Australia have welcomed the
apology they still believe that more can
be done that includes health care which
survivors say is still difficult to
navigate
I think it would be lovely to see that
from this apology that um that the
government step up and plug some of the
holes that are in that program the
little m's with me 24/7 I get no no
um um break from it it it's impacted
every aspect of my life walking uh
dressing eating drinking um every
aspect for Trish Jackson This apology
won't change everyday life and is too
late for those who died but she says
it's a step forward in the healing
process Sarah Clark aler
Brisbane make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer